All right, so let's get started. My name
is Marco Pavone, I'll be the instructor
for AA203, optimal and learning-based
control. I'm a professor in the
Department of Aeronautics and
Astronautics. I also have appointments
in
computer science and electrical
engineering.
I run the autonomous systems lab and my
work is broadly in the field of robot
autonomy, learning-based control for
robotic systems, system architecting,
reasoning models for robotics. So,
essentially decision-making autonomy for
robotic systems. I also have a bit of a
dual role. I am a faculty here at
Stanford. I also lead autonomous system
research at Nvidia.
So, in this class, we're going to have a
four graded problem sets, more or less
evenly distributed throughout the
quarter, which will entail a mixture of
theoretical
questions and coding questions.
Put them out in Python.
And then we have a final exam that is
scheduled for June 8th from 3:30 to
6:30. The homework will make up the
majority of your grade, 80% with each
homework accounting for 20%. The final
exam will account for 20% of your grade.
And then we're going to give a bonus
points up to 5% depending on your
participation on Ed. For example, if you
answer a question of your colleagues in
a meaningful way.
It's important that you keep up with the
homework, but stuff happens.
So, we are providing a six free late
days
that can be used throughout the quarter,
and a maximum of two late days will be
allowed on a given assignment.
So, try to be a bit strategic in how you
use your late days.
All the material
that is needed in order to understand
this class uh
will be provided on the website. In
particular, what you really need are the
lecture slides and then attending the
lectures and then doing the homework.
But, we also provide a set of uh course
notes that are available at the website
listed here. In the syllabus, we also
provide a list of books and references
that might be helpful. They're not
necessary to study for this class, but
if you want to get deeper in some
topics, at least you have some handy
references.
During the first 4 weeks, we're going to
have recitations on Fridays from 1:30 to
2:30.
So, those uh
can be attended in person. I would
encourage you to attend those in person,
but they will be recorded as well in
case that you cannot make uh the time.
>> [snorts]
>> So, the goal of um
um
these recitations is to give you some
uh foundational knowledge on some of the
tools that we will be using throughout
this class. Such as, for example, Jax or
regression models. If you're already
familiar with those topics, then no need
to attend the recitations, but in
general, it should be uh a good overview
of important tools.
So, what do you need to know in order to
succeed in this class? Well, you have to
be quite uh comfortable with uh
calculus. We'll see quite a bit of uh
multivariable uh calculus. So, the
vector calculus, ordinary differential
equations.
You won't need particularly
sophisticated knowledge in terms of
solving for differential equations, but
at least a good understanding of what a
differential equation uh is.
You need a strong familiarity with
linear algebra. I'm providing here some
course numbers to give you a reference
in terms of the material uh we expect
you to be
knowledgeable
with.
And then it would be great if you have a
some familiarity with the optimization.
It's not necessary in the sense that the
class is going to be self-contained. It
would just make the class a bit easier
for you.
Same [snorts] goes for machine learning
and course and control. You don't need
to have taken these classes necessarily,
but it will basically ease the
understanding of this course and will
allow you to get a bit deeper.
In order for you to gauge to what extent
you're ready for this class, we provide
a homework zero. So, homework zero is
not graded.
So, it's there just for you to gauge
whether your knowledge level is
appropriate for taking this class or
not.
We'll be providing solutions, of course.
The homework zero is already on the
website. So, at your convenience in the
next few days, just look at those
problems, try to see whether you can
solve those problems. Don't use ChatGPT.
Most likely they're solvable by ChatGPT.
Use it as a standalone test for
yourselves.
If you're a bit rusty, that's okay. At
least you understand in which area
you're rusty and then you know what to
strengthen your knowledge.
If you find those exercises extremely
difficult, then probably it's good for
you to take some of the other courses
here and then consider this class maybe
next year.
So, as you will see when I talk about
the syllabus to be more in detail,
this class aims more at the breadth over
depth. So, in a single class I want to
give you
a good overview of all the main
techniques in optimal control and
learning-based control.
Of course, optimal control is a field
that is a 50 years
um old. So, there is a very broad
literature, widely used. And as it
pertains to learning-based control, as
you probably know, this is one of the
hottest topics in the field of AI. So,
how to control robots with the learning
based techniques. So, a lot of
techniques, I will try to give you a
good taxonomy of these techniques and
then
good understanding of the main
techniques out there. But, we'll be
covering a lot of stuff and necessarily
we'll be trading off a little bit depth
with
breadth.
Uh which means that if you want to get
deeper in some of the techniques, some
self-study is necessary.
Now, the class is in general considered
uh quite challenging. It's not extreme,
but definitely because of the variety of
topics we are going to going to look at,
you're going to be challenged in
different dimensions in terms of your
knowledge of calculus, your knowledge of
uh statistical analysis, and so on and
so forth. So, be prepared.
All right. So, any questions so far
about the mechanics of the course?
Pretty straightforward.
Yeah.
>> What is the
uh schedule for
>> They're going to be released on
uh Fridays.
>> Yes, Fridays.
>> Yeah, they're due on Fridays.
>> Oh, yeah, it's impossible to get them
all done in
Yeah, for all of us.
>> You can do it in three weeks.
>> Um
>> But, yeah, they are going to spread out
uniformly throughout the quarter.
All right. So,
now that we have a good understanding of
the mechanics, so that's the boring part
of the class, let's talk about the
motivation for this course
and the syllabus.
So, this is a class about control. So, I
assume that all of you are knowledgeable
about the concept of a control, but
essentially you have a system, a
physical system, but could also be a
financial system,
and you want to act on the system to
make sure that this system has some
desired response. For example,
uh
you may want to control the stability of
financial market, or you want to control
the trajectory of a drone.
At an abstract level,
you have a system, as again, it could be
physical, it could be a digital sphere.
And you have a sensor that allows you to
get some information about the state of
the system. So, if this is a car, for
example, the sensor might be a camera
sensor that gets an observation about
the surrounding environment, plus maybe
some additional sensor that allow you to
uh measure, for example, your speed.
And then, based on the measurement that
you get about the state of your system,
and based on some high-level goal,
referred to as a reference, but for
example, you want to your vehicle to
change lane, or going straight at a
given desired speed, you use these two
information pieces of information
to uh synthesize a control action
through a function referred to as a
controller,
that is then exerted on the system, and
then the system produces an output. For
example, the control could be the
steering angle and the throttle of a
car, and then you have a response, so
the acceleration of the car. And then,
the key idea here is that you keep
iterating on this process, so you
compute an action, you observe the
response of the system, you measure that
response, and then you recalculate your
control action.
As a human, obviously, you do close loop
control uh since the time you were born.
Your eyes are your sensors, you perceive
the environment, you use that
information to decide how to move your
joints. Your high-level reference will
be, for example, I want to go to that
door.
And then I try to
uh plan my actions and execute those
actions accordingly.
So, that's the standard setup of uh a
control problem. So, if you're taking a
class in
uh frequency domain uh control, so
essentially PID controls,
that's the plot the diagram you should
be familiar with.
Another example is, for example, is if
you want to
control um
uh your room temperature. In that case,
your home is the system, the room
temperature will be the output, that's
what you measure through a thermometer.
Your thermostat setting will be the
reference, then you use that information
to
um decide on the gas flow rate, the
goal, and that signal goes into the
furnace that then causes a response from
the home.
The beauty of control is that actually
you can be quite judicious in terms of
how you model uh the system, and this
model actually could be learned from
data. For example,
if this was a class in um computational
fluid dynamics,
and then you pose the problem of how do
you
control or set the temperature of your
shower,
they would say, "Well, let's build a
thermodynamic model about how the water
affects the heat that propagates on your
body." In control, we try to be a little
more pragmatic. So, that model could be
something much more simplified. Or we
could bypass a model
uh itself. Uh for example, when you
control the shower, basically, what is
your rule?
If you move the
knob right, it's warmer. If you move the
uh
knob left, that's colder. And that's
your model. So, there is a lot of,
uh uh, judicious reasoning that goes
into modeling, and we'll see some of
that, too.
Now, of course, life is hard. So, you
are setting up your control system, but
then, uh, you have to face a number of
challenges. For example, there might be
disturbances that affect the evolution
of your system. Like, for example, an
aircraft that is flying, and then there
is a wind gust that is perturbing your,
uh,
trajectory from the desired or nominal
trajectory.
Or your sensor may not be perfect, so
you might have a, uh, measurement noise.
So, these are all challenges that are
well tackled by classical controls or
frequency-based control systems, PD
controllers.
And in general, what are the control
desiderata that you would state in a
basic control course? Like, for example,
engineering 105, uh, here at Stanford.
Well, you want to see your system to be
stable. There are a few different
definition of stability, like internal
stability, external stability. But, in
general,
by stability we,
uh, we say, we mean that the system
doesn't go out of whack. So, basically,
the system output is under control. It
stays bounded. It doesn't do something
crazy.
Uh, we have an objective, in general, of
tracking something. We have a reference
signal, for example, the setting for
your thermostat. We want to make sure
that, uh,
the, uh, home temperature,
uh, tracks as as close as possible, uh,
as possible that
We want to reject disturbances, so we
are, you know, piloting our, I mean, we
have an autopilot that is controlling
the aircraft. Uh, there is a wind gust.
We want to make sure that this wind gust
doesn't perturb
the trajectory of the aircraft too much.
And we want the controller to be robust.
Robust means that the controller should
be able to perform well even if
your model is, uh, inaccurate. Of
course, your model is always inaccurate.
It's never like a, perfect perfect
replica of the physical system. Or
simply, maybe your model is very
accurate,
but your system is changing through
time.
Because, for example, the temperature
changes and then the response of your
actuator might change, too. So, you want
to make sure that the controller is
controller is robust to those changes.
So, you take a class in
classical control, such as engineering
105,
and
actually, you have tools to address all
of these desiderata. So, what is
missing?
Well, there are two things that are
missing here.
First,
we haven't discussed at all how much we
care about the performance. There are
many different ways to achieve uh
uh the objective of stability, but is
there a best way to do so? Like, for
example, the way that is most economical
in terms of how much control effort
we spend.
Second of all,
in this plot here,
I'm saying that the someone is giving
you a reference, but where is this
reference coming from?
I mean, maybe if you want to control the
temperature of a room, it is obvious,
but if you want to control the path of
an aircraft, where is that path coming
from?
This is the so-called element of
planning, where you want to come up in
the first place with that reference
signal.
And third, learning. So,
everything we've discussed so far
essentially assumed that uh
um a model of the system is known, but
what if that is not the case? Or maybe
it's the case, but as I said,
the system might change during
operation. So, how do we adapt with
respect to those changes?
So, these considerations lead to the
core of this class. How we go beyond
classical control in such a way that we
can broadly address these the key
considerations. What is the best way to
control the system? How do we do so if
we don't have [snorts] a a perfect model
uh or acquiring that model is
excessively complicated and so we want
to learn it from data. And then how we
make sure that all of the components of
our closed loop, also the reference
signal, is accounted for in our control
analysis.
So, that's really the objective of uh
optimal and learning-based control.
Optimality speaks to the performance
objective. Learning speaks to the desire
of learning a model from data, adapting
the controller based on the data that
you acquire.
As I said, optimal learning-based
control based control has a long
history.
It dates back about 50 years.
It uh it started actually during the
Cold War.
Uh
the motivation was to
optimize the trajectory of a ballistic
missiles both ways and accordingly there
was a a pioneer in the United States and
a pioneer in the Soviet Union. The
pioneer in the United States, his name
is Richard Bellman.
If you have taken a class in
decision-making and so on, you might
have heard
of the Bellman equation. So, it's that
Bellman.
And in the Soviet Union,
uh the pioneer was uh Pontryagin, which
was a blind Soviet mathematician.
And they developed their theories in a
fairly independent way. Of course, there
was not a lot of knowledge sharing at
that time, but interestingly,
there are a lot of commonalities. I
mean, the theories and the methods are a
bit different, but there are a lot of
commonalities between uh
the two.
So,
this is how our class is going to be
structured.
So, first of all,
there is a difference between the notion
of open-loop optimal control and a
closed-loop optimal control. We'll
discuss this a bit more formally later,
but basically in open-loop optimal
control, we compute a a sequence of uh
control actions, and we assume that
we're going to blindly follow those
execute those control actions without
acquiring further information from
the
uh from the world. Essentially, I want
to go to that door, I plan my
trajectory, I close my eyes, and then I
hope for the best. So, that's open-loop
control.
Of course,
yeah, it has its challenges. So, for
example, if he uh stands up, and I have
my eyes closed, I might crash into him.
So, that motivates closed-loop control,
that yeah, sure, you plan your action,
but with understanding that you're going
to constantly close the loop, so
measuring and re-optimize your actions.
So, we're going to first look at methods
uh
where we assume
an open-loop control framework. So, why
It seems that open-loop is less powerful
than closed-loop, and that's true.
The advantage of open-loop is that it's
though extremely efficient
computationally.
So, it does have an advantage.
So, it's useful to start looking at
these methods, and for some applications
actually uh open-loop, as we will
discuss, is um
a useful control methodology.
Within the open-loop class of methods,
we have a two different class of
methods, indirect methods and direct
methods. I'll explain the differences
later on. But essentially, the first 2
weeks, 3 weeks of the quarter, we will
focus on open-loop control
methodologies. Roughly speaking,
very efficient computationally,
but potentially uh not robust to changes
in environment, like for example, your
colleague standing up standing up.
Closed-loop,
much more powerful, account for
disturbances natively,
but computationally more complicated
because of course you have to account
for different contingencies that might
occur during the execution of your
control loop.
Within the closed-loop branch, there are
two sub-branches, dynamic programming
DP. Those of you that have taken classes
in decision-making may already be
familiar with dynamic programming. And
the Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman and
Hamilton-Jacobi-Isaacs
equations that are basically
continuous-time formulation of dynamic
programming, useful because they provide
uh so-called
uh reachability control paradigms that
are useful to build a safety guard rails
around controllers. We'll see all of
this stuff later. Here, I just want to
give you a high-level overview of what
we're going to do. So, about 3 weeks
here,
couple of weeks here.
So, we said open-loop, computationally
very efficient, but potentially
uh brittle as a control optimal control
strategy. Closed-loop, powerful, but
also computationally expensive. Is there
a best of both worlds? Yes, that is
called MPC, model predictive control.
We'll So, we will see we'll use MPC,
which after PID control, I would claim
is the most uh
widespread control methodology. We will
frame it as a bridge between a
closed-loop control and open-loop
control.
Roughly what you do, you solve a problem
in open-loop,
and then uh you execute the first chunk
of your control sequence, and then you
close the loop, and you recompute your
open-loop control sequence. So, at any
point in time, you solve an open-loop
control problem. But, the way that the
MPC gets executed is by iteratively
taking measurements. I mean, this will
become a clearer later. And of course,
there are variations
uh on the theme, but this is at a high
level what's happening with MPC. So,
we'll spend about uh two, three lectures
here.
So, everything here on the bottom side
assumes that we know a model of the
system, at least an approximate model.
In the second part of the class, we will
forego that assumption.
And we won't assume anymore that we have
direct knowledge of the model of the
system. So, we have to use data
in order to infer that model.
So, we'll be using
well-known ideas from the field of a
control where, for example, the model
has to be identified from data.
And use that ideas to set up the
data-driven version of optimal control
or adaptive version of the optimal
control.
So, basically, optimal control when the
model is not known exactly.
And we will look at the three
broad methods to solve the problem. So,
the first one is uh
uh imitation learning. So, roughly
speaking,
we just get some demonstration of what
an optimal policy looks like, and we try
to mimic it.
That's a possible way to compute an
optimal policy.
And then we're going to look at
reinforcement learning. So, instead of
just mimicking like an expert like a
teacher [snorts] such as myself,
you try to learn by trial and error.
And there are couple of ways to do so,
model-based and model-free.
In general, nothing is in uh
uh dichotomy with each other. So, there
are many different ways to blend all
these techniques. In fact, it's quite
common, for example, to learn a driving
policy in autonomous driving through
imitation learning to bootstrap a good
policy, and then improve on that uh
policy through reinforcement learning.
That is also true, for example, for
reasoning models for autonomy. You start
first with a supervised fine-tuning
training pipeline, and then you try to
further improve your model with
different instantiation of reinforcement
learning. So,
uh
I will highlight different ways of
hybridizing these concepts, but please
keep in mind that you shouldn't view
each concept in competition with each
other. There are a lot of ways to blend
all these techniques together. So,
first half of the course, we assume that
we know the model. We're going to look
at the two broad techniques. One are
open-loop optimal control, closed-loop
control, and then we'll look at MPC as a
bridge between the two. Then in the
second half of the class, we'll move
into data-driven optimal control, and
we'll be looking at the three main
methodologies, imitation learning, and
then reinforcement learning through its
model-based and model-free
uh implementation.
Any questions here?
The beauty of this class
is that you have a a very holistic
overview
of all the methods. And that's important
because in practice, these methods get
uh hybridized.
So, it's important that uh you
understand model-free reinforcement
learning, but you do also understand the
what more what more more classical
direct methods for optimal control
entails.
In modern robotic systems, we use all of
those.
Despite the hype that
visual instruction models are solving
everything.
Right? Great.
So, what are what is the course's goal?
Is to learn the theoretical
implementation aspects of main
techniques in optimal learning-based
control. So, that's why this course,
you're going to have both a theoretical
exercises, but also practical exercises,
mostly through uh Python.
And second, I want to do so by providing
a unified framework. So, not just uh
uh
classical optimal control, or not just
decision the decision-making version of
optimal control, which will be dynamic
programming, not just reinforcement
learning, but actually overarching theme
that connects all these methodologies.
So that you as a designer know uh
when to use the best tool.
Never get in love too much with a given
tool. It's very common for a
technologist to really get in love with
uh
you know, some version of imitation
learning and then use the tool for every
possible problem in the world. That's
not how robotics or optimal control
works.
Any questions?
Are you excited?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Yeah. And uh uh
Let Give me 10 minutes and we'll talk a
little more about the performance index.
Performance index, yes. It's up to you.
It's up to the designer to decide. But
definitely can take into account the
desire that your system doesn't go out
of whack, for sure. But in addition,
might also take into account uh
uh
control effort. So you want to do so by
minimizing your control effort as much
as possible. You might take into account
uh time.
You want to do something as quick as
possible. But by the way, that is
typically at odds with uh minimizing
control effort. Typically, if you want
to do something very fast, you have to
spend more fuel. So then is there is a
question of uh how you do do you trade
off uh
potentially conflicting objectives. So
we we'll see in a second how for the
sake of this class, but in general, the
field of optimal control uh the
performance index is derived.
And is a fairly
uh
general formulation that allows you to
encode many of these considerations.
Which is a good segue into
how do we define an optimal control
uh problem? So, I talked at length about
it. What is it?
Interestingly enough, so all the
methodologies that uh I've shown you
before in that crowded slide, by the
way, that will be the agenda that will
stay with us
for the rest of the quarter.
So, all those methodologies solve
exactly the same problem.
And the same problem that uh I'm going
to show to you in a second,
uh
its formulation entails three main
ingredients.
So, mathematical description of the
system to be controlled,
that either we know it or maybe we don't
know it, but we assume that there is
some
uh
underlying uh system with a mathematical
model that uh is being controlled.
The second ingredient is constraints,
that is that are typically not
explicitly discussed in
classical feedback control, but in
optimal control we want to account for
them.
Which is crucial, for example, in
autonomous car, you don't want to crash
uh
you know, on another car. So, that's a
constraint.
And then,
as your colleague was alluding to, the
specification of a performance
criterion.
So, what do we mean by mathematical
model? Nothing particularly fancy or
new here. For us, the mathematical model
of a system
is a set of ordinary differential
equations.
So, here X1, X2, Xn represent the state
of the system.
So, basically, the set of variables that
together with the notion of the
control allow us to predict what the
system will do in the future.
The use U1 to UN, which are the control
inputs. In general, you may have a
multiple control inputs, throttle
command and steering command in the case
of a car.
And then uh
functions F1, F2, all the way to FN that
tells us how the state will evolve in
the future as a function the current
value of the state variables and current
value of the control
uh variables. So, for us
the
notion that allow us to map the present
in the future is the notion of an
ordinary differential equation.
Now, if you see an ODE, it may seem a
bit cryptic. Why I'm saying that an
ordinary differential equation is the
mechanism we use in order to reason
about how a future how a system will
evolve in the future.
Well, my pragmatic view of a
differential equation is as follows.
So, you have x.t
equal A of xt
ut
and t.
Well, by the way, in this in this in
this class, a dot means uh derivative
with respect to time.
Two dots means uh double derivative with
respect to time.
So, when I'm saying oh, instead of
calling A, let me call it F. So, this is
a simplified case where we have one
state variable, one control variable
and then one function F that tells us
how the state will evolve in the future.
So, why I'm saying that an ordinary
differential equation for the
perspective of optimal control is the
mechanisms that allow us to claim that
we understand how the system will evolve
in the future.
Well, remember that x.
is equal to by definition
derivative with respect to time of xt.
And a derivative can be approximated as
xt + delta t
- x of t
divided by delta t
where delta t is a small time increment,
say 0.5 0.1 seconds.
So, if you put this back in here,
what you get
Oops.
Let me put it here. So,
you put this one back in here.
So, what you get is that the x
t plus delta t minus x t
over delta t
is equal to a of x I don't know f
f of x t
u t t
which implies
that x of t plus delta t
equal
x t
plus delta t
of f of x t
u t
and t.
So, you see that if you know the value
of the state x and the value of the
control u
and you know the function f
then you also know what the value of the
state will be delta t
time steps in the future.
So, that's why when a mathematician sees
an ODE, he sees a beautiful mathematical
object. When I see an ODE,
I see a mechanism to predict the future.
>> [clears throat]
>> Does that make sense?
So, that makes it basically
all of this mathematical stuff a little
bit less cryptic.
And in this class in general, we're
assuming that the f can be
anything. So, we're not assuming
linearity. So, we're already moving
quite a bit away
from the more standard control setup
where we make a linear assumption into
your system.
Just for notational purposes, we
typically
define a a bold vector X. So, this bold
as the set of state variables X1T
XNT
and the set of U variables UT
which is also bold.
U1T UM
T. And if you do so,
we can write the set of ordinary
differential equation in more compact
form
as in here, where now F is the
concatenation of all the functions F1,
F2, all the way to FM.
One thing I'd like to note here is that
sometime
this mechanism to predict the future, so
what the next state will be,
might not only be in a function of time
or of state and control, but also
an explicit function of time.
Which means that in some systems, given
the same state and control, depending on
when you hit the specific value of the
state and for the same value of control,
you might get a a different response
depending on time.
For example, maybe it could be
day or night, your system might respond
to quite differently whether you are
during the day or during the night
even for the same state and control.
A history of control input values is
called a control history. So, this is
just terminology, but we'll be using
this terminology quite a bit.
A history of state values during the
interval T0 to TF is called a
trajectory.
T0 is typically referred to as the
initial time of operations, that's the
symbol we'll be using. TF, F stands for
final,
uh is the final time of operations.
Let me give you a very simple example
that you should already be familiar
with, a double integrator. So, we have a
a cart moving on the horizontal plane.
We only have one state variable,
which is the displacement of the center
of the cart from the origin. So, we
assume that the origin is here. So, S is
telling us how much we travel on the
left or to the right of the origin.
So, we assume that we are just
controlling the acceleration of this
cart.
So, the equations of motion is that the
acceleration of the system, so the
double derivative, is equal to the input
we apply, so essentially the force we
apply to it.
Or
basically, we're assuming that here the
mass of this cart is equal to one.
So, this is our dynamical model. The
only point that I want to make here is
that sometimes dynamical models come in
the form of a second second order
differential equations. I mean, all
dynamical systems should be second-order
systems since you, you know, uh
evolve at the basic level at the level
of accelerations.
So, now you might say, well, this is a
second-order system, but you're saying
that in this class
we focus on models where we have a
system of first-order differential
equations.
Can we reconcile the two?
And the answer is yes, as you may
already know, you can always map a
higher higher order differential
equation into a system of first-order
differential equations. And this is a
one-to-one mapping.
So, for example, here, how does that
work?
It works by adding
one state variable,
which in this case would be denoted by
B, and then codes the notion of speed.
So, we reason in terms of
two state variables. So, we augment the
state vector with a new state variable
V.
And then
S dot
is equal to V. I mean, this is by
definition, the time derivative of the
displacement
is equal to velocity.
And then the time derivative of the
velocity is equal to the acceleration.
That is what
uh
what uh our input represents.
So, you see how we went from a
second-order
differential equation describing our
system into a set of two first-order
differential equations. And we are back
to our basic setup.
So, bottom line is that if you have a
system that is described by
a higher-order [snorts]
differential equations, before you apply
the techniques explained in this class,
first you translate it into a set of a
first-order differential equations, and
uh and then we're back to the standard
formalism. And that that can be always
be done
by using the trick of adding states.
This case specifically is an interesting
one, because this is uh
a linear system.
So, if you're familiar with linear
systems, typically you present them in
matrix format,
where you have a state matrix and an
input matrix.
Not important now, but just to uh link
this back to what you may already know
from uh classical control theory. So,
you can write the system
in terms of a matrix A times the state
vector plus a matrix B times the input
vector.
In this case, the input vector is just
one control variable, so it's just uh A.
A is referred to as the state matrix, B
is referred to as the input matrix.
Okay. That's what I wanted to say about
models.
Constraints.
Clearly
in general when you control a system, we
have to reason about
constraints. For a physical system, we
don't want to hit a wall.
Of course, the amount of control we have
available is bounded. We cannot have a
thrust level that is above a certain
quantity. Sometimes it can be below a
certain quantity.
So, there are accordingly different ways
of setting constraints. Typically, we
have a constraint on our initial
condition. So, we know where we start
from.
Sometimes we might have a constraint on
our desired final condition. We want to
hit a very precise point. Like, for
example, you want to
send a spacecraft to Mars
and you want to land on a Gale crater. I
mean, just to make it up. I before
joining Stanford, I was an employee of
JPL. So, that's the problem that I was
looking at. So, you know, landing on a
specific point on Mars is your um
terminal constraint.
Sometimes you have it, sometimes you
don't have it.
Typically, you want your state to avoid
some bad regions of the state space,
which could be formulated as a lower
bound and upper bound for the state
variables. But, there are also more
creative uh
ways of setting up state constraints.
For example, you want to stay outside of
a circle. A circle could be a person,
and you want your robot to stay outside
of uh
the physical envelope of that person.
You want your control input to satisfy
lower bound and input and lower bound
and upper bound constraints and so on.
So, that's pretty
um
intuitive. There is a lot of freedom in
optimal control in terms of how you
state
your constraints. With some caveats, of
course. If you have a very convoluted
expressions of your constraints, then
the mathematical procedures we're going
to see later on might get to be more
complicated.
A control history that satisfies the
control constraints are referred to as
an admissible control if they satisfy
the constraints at all time.
And a state trajectory that satisfies
the constraints at all times is referred
to as an admissible trajectory.
Three, performance measure.
Optimal control stands for the fact that
we're trying to find a control sequence
or control policy that
uh is the best possible one you can come
up with.
But best with respect to what? I mean,
that's the role of the performance
measure.
There are different ways you can set up
a performance measure. In this class, we
look only
at this performance measure here.
Which might sound a bit cryptic. So, my
point now I'm going to spend 3 minutes
to show you that this is not cryptic at
all. It's actually very intuitive.
It's not the most general way of
defining a performance measure,
but
it provides a good trade-off between
what
at the end of the day
uh is computationally feasible
in terms of synthesizing a control law
and also being general.
That's always a little bit a tension in
optimal control.
You want to be as sophisticated as you
can in how you express the problem, but
to the point that you can solve the
problem. If you make it too complicated,
then
if you can't solve it in a reasonable
amount of time, then it's useless.
Okay. So, what does this performance
measure really mean?
So, this performance measure has two
main
components. [snorts]
This component here with the H function
and this component here with the
integral.
So, first let's start with the H
of XTF.
H of X TF
TF.
So, this is referred to as the
terminal cost.
TF is the final time. As a reminder, we
assume that we solve the problem between
time T0
to the final time TF, say 10 seconds
from now.
And so, this measures how unhappy we are
if, after applying the control sequence
we have decided, we end up in state X TF
at time TF.
For example, say that we want to do
tracking.
Ideally, we want to arrive at a very
specific location at the final time.
In which case,
the function H X TF TF could take the
form of X
evaluated at the final time, so X TF,
minus XF, which is your desired position
at the final time, squared.
So that if your state, under your
control,
hits the state X TF that is equal XF,
that is what you want, then this is
zero.
But the moment there is a deviation,
this cost starts growing.
So, this is an example of how you might
use the terminal cost to promote a
control
strategy that brings you as close as
possible at your desired destination XF
at the final time.
Any questions here?
That's the most intuitive part.
This part is a little bit less
intuitive. You have an integral, it's a
little bit unclear what that means, but
basically what this means
view G
as the cost that you incur per unit of
time. And then, view the integral as
essentially a summation from uh time T0,
when you start operations, to time TF.
So, basically this models a cumulative
cost
along your state trajectory.
G
of XU
is the state that you incur at a
specific time, at a specific rate at uh
which you incur that cost.
Uh if you're in a state X of T and you
use control U of T.
Of course, you don't care about just the
cost that you incur at time 0.1. You
care about the cumulative cost in
general.
So, that's why you take an integral.
So, this first term here
models how unhappy you are at the end of
operations. This term here is uh a
cumulative cost term that puts together
all the costs that are incurred
throughout the execution of your control
trajectory.
So, for example
typical
um
So, G is referred to as the stage-wise
cost. It's basically the cost that you
accrue per unit of time. Typical cost
could be
UT
squared.
So, this models control effort.
U squared often times has the notion of
energy.
So, that's how much how much energy
you're spending per unit of time. You
take an integral, you have the overall
fuel that you have spent.
Of course, many other formulations are
possible.
If you're familiar with dynamic
programming, that's not too different
from your dynamic programming cost.
Well, simply because you're solving the
same problem.
So, this becomes a summation, if you
remember from dynamic programming. So,
your cost is basically a summation of
stage-wise cost.
So, the framework is exactly the same.
Yeah.
>> Um is that all squared?
>> All of them there. So, for example,
um
your G
could be
Your G could be X of T
minus X reference
at time T
square. So, this is your
desired trajectory that you want to hit,
and this is your actual trajectory.
And then your X X D F D F, for example,
could be equal to T F squared.
You are also penalizing how long it took
to get it to a given
Which brings to an interesting point.
So, T0 in general is given, is the
initial time operations. TF might be
given or might be subject of
optimization, too.
So, in some cases, you know that you
want to optimize your operations within
a time window of 10 seconds, in which
case TF is equal to 10. But in some
other cases, as you're saying, you want
to track a trajectory and get to some
point,
uh but you're not specifying the final
time. You're saying, I just want to do
it as fast as possible, but at the same
time, I want to keep the trajectory
error small. So, in that case, TF will
be free, and so you would need also to
account for some cost
for the final time, so that you encode
the notion of minimizing time.
So, great question.
So, all of this to say that what is the
optimal control problem is the problem
of finding an admissible control U star.
Admissible means that we are satisfying
the control constraints,
which causes the system X. = f of X U T
to follow an admissible trajectory X
star such that U star and X star jointly
minimizes this cost cost functional.
Note that once you select U, X is
uniquely determined by the ODE. But, of
course, the final cost depends on both
the value of X and the value of U.
Your optimization variable variable
variable is U T.
As you will see, we can
I'll get to your question.
As you will see, this is an optimization
problem. We are optimizing over the
space of control sequences U T.
So, it has a strong connection to the
field of optimization, but there is a
catch.
In optimization, if you're familiar with
optimization,
you typically have uh
a finite number of decision variables,
you know,
minimizing over X1 and X2
uh X1 squared plus X2 squared.
So, you pick two numbers that minimizes
this thing.
You have two decision variables. You
have to decide what is the value of X1,
what is the value of X2.
Here,
you're in a much more challenging
situation.
U T
is a function of time. So, essentially,
you want to uh pick the optimal values
for U T zero,
U T zero plus epsilon,
U T zero plus two epsilon,
and so on with epsilon arbitrarily
small. So, indeed,
you don't have a very large number of
decision variables. At least in the
continuous time formulation, you have an
infinite amount of variables.
So, through this class, you expand your
mindset, go from
finite
dimensions to infinite dimensions.
So, that's why this problem is also
referred to as an infinite dimensional
optimization problem.
So, that sounds scary, but we'll see
that actually we have tools at our
disposal. Many of those actually
recycled from the
more classical finite dimensional
optimization literature.
And of course, I will uh highlight these
bridges in the next uh couple of
lectures.
Now, you might say, "You're giving us
this very specific performance
criterion." Well, a couple of comments.
First of all, this is quite general.
There are a lot of uh
uh desiderata we can fold into this
general formulation.
But second of all, if you go even more
general, you could,
but then it would be very uh very
difficult to find solving algorithms.
Why? The integral is essentially a
summation.
So, roughly speaking, I know that I'm
recorded, so I hope that you don't quote
me, but roughly speaking, what is what
does the summation gives you? Especially
essentially it allows you to chop the
problem into pieces and find a smart
ways to chopping it.
For example, this idea of chopping leads
uh in the case of uh
a discrete time formulation, but it's
also analogous for the continuous time
formulation, to the principle principle
of optimality. You might have heard of
it if you study decision making, which
allows which allows to dramatically
decrease the number of solutions that
you have to search over. The moment you
break this kind of additive assumption
uh additive structure in your
performance criterion, all this
structure goes out of the window,
and so, you can't really use it anymore.
Computation becomes uh extremely
challenging.
We'll see that a little better when we
talk about principle of optimality and
dynamic programming recursions and so
on. But for now, trust me
that this is a general formulation.
There is certainly some structure, and
the reason why we put some structure is
to make sure that actually we can solve
these problems.
>> I was wondering if there was any
specific reason we chose this
or write h separately because if we
didn't distinguish between only include
the final state and so on.
>> Yeah, you're right. In some cases
actually the cost can be represented
both in the final and here.
Uh it depends also a little bit on
convenience.
So, a few comments.
Here, at least in this formulation, the
uh
we're trying to find a global
minimum.
Even though sometimes we have to be
happy with a local minimum.
We do have challenges. So, in addition
to the fact that it is an
infinite-dimensional problem,
it is not guaranteed that actually uh a
solution exists. And if it exists, it's
not guaranteed to be unique. So, this
poses some challenges that we'll see in
terms of how we solve these problems.
Another point is that even though we
solve this problem as a minimization,
uh if you have a maximization problem,
you can always convert it to this
formalism because every maximization
problem can be written as a minimization
problem with a a minus sign in front of
the objective.
Interestingly, does that make sense?
So, if you don't want to maximize
something, it's equivalent to minimizing
the minus thing that you want to
maximize.
And here you start seeing a little bit
of uh a shift. So, in the control
theoretic the control theoretical
community
and the computer science communities
have developed slightly different
terminologies.
So, for example, in control
we refer to the performance index as J
and we call it cost.
In computer science, it is referred to
as the reward. It is referred to R and
the goal is to maximize.
I leave it to you the psychological
considerations about why a community
looks at maximizing thing and another
one minimizing things. But my point is
is the same.
Or for example, in terms of uh
notation
in control, we refer to the state as X.
In computer science, it is referred to
as S.
In control, we refer to control as U. In
computer science, it is referred to as
A, action.
Yeah, I'm I'm iterating through all of
them.
And this is the start of the quarter, so
who knows what happens at the end. Okay,
so.
Anyways,
uh we'll mostly be using
uh
this notation, especially for the first
2/3 of the class.
But for the last third
we switch to this notation.
Just to be a little bit more
uh similar to, you know, papers and uh
publications.
But I just want to make sure that you
don't get tripped. I mean, we're talking
about the same things. X S U A
R and or J.
So,
couple more things before um we switch
to the first real topic of this course.
Forms of optimal control. This is
something that already have alluded to.
And here we have to be careful. This
seems to be a fairly nuanced difference
but extremely important and people get
tripped over and over. So, I mean, there
are even senior researchers that
sometimes do not really properly
appreciate the difference between open
loop control and a closed loop control.
So, as I mentioned, [snorts]
uh
you can do control in two ways. You can
either think of optimizing you
purely as a function of a time and
initial condition,
or you
as a function of uh
the current state and the initial
condition.
As explained, is more almost impossible
to understand what I'm saying.
But again, let me do
um
an example. So, it's same example as
before. You I want to go to that door.
Optimizing a a function of only time is
equivalent to uh this time here,
I optimize a a sequence of uh steps. So,
basically the sequence of uh
uh steps for my legs.
And then I close my eyes.
So, I do not allow myself to measure
anything about uh the current state of
the world.
And at time t, I'm going to use the
precomputed action u star of x 0 x 0 t,
no matter what happens around me.
So, if your colleague stands up, I'm
going to just crash into him.
So, that's open loop control. Open
because no you don't have this notion of
loop closure feedback.
Closed loop control, you try to optimize
over you over broader class of uh
possible trajectories.
Of course, this is a a subset of this,
right?
Not only those that map a time into a
given control,
but also take into account any possible
states that you might uh visit.
So, this is a much more powerful way of
uh parameterizing
uh a control trajectory because it's
telling you not only what to do if
anything goes nominal, so you don't
stand up, but also what I should be
doing if something goes off nominal, so
you stand up.
Of course, to do so, I have to keep my
eyes open in order to measure the state.
Pi is referred to also as policy. The
policy is the notion of
uh
a function that maps the state into an
optimal control action.
Pi is super common.
E is somewhat arbitrary. Different
people have slightly different notation.
I would say that pi is the gold standard
for a closed-loop policy. For open-loop,
um
no, also because typically
the initial condition
the dependence on initial condition is
just assumed, so it's not even made
explicit. Here, I'm just doing it to be
pedantic. And so, people just write uh
uh
u star of t period
to denote an open-loop control
trajectory, and then pi of x t and t
to denote a closed-loop. So, this will
be the more standard. But here, I want
to be pedantic, and so I come up with
this additional letter e for lack of a
better term.
It seems to be nuanced. It seems to be
that academic, but it is very
consequential. So, we will see over and
over throughout this class uh
methods that aim at computing open-loop
control sequences, methods that are
aimed at computing the more general
concept of a closed-loop policy, and
what are the tradeoffs there are in
terms of a computational efficiency,
um
robustness, and so on.
One more thing.
I presented the formulation in
continuous time,
but there is uh
an equivalent in discrete time, which is
essentially identical,
is
you can derive it simply by discretizing
having a set. So, basically, the
ordinary differential equations
or the cost function in discrete time,
this this the evolution of the system is
no longer described in terms of
differential equations, but rather
um discrete update equations.
K is the discrete time stage.
time step
K + 1 is the next time step.
The cost function is exactly the same,
but now the integral has been replaced
by a summation.
You have uh
control constraints, meaning that your
control variables have to belong to some
set capital U of desired or allowed
control variables.
And then you want to find a set of
controls such that your cost is
minimized.
So, the concept is exactly the same and
the same notion of closed-loop and
open-loop control applies.
You're probably more familiar uh about
this formulation when extended to the
stochastic setting, which is the setting
of Markov decision processes. So, we
look at that formulation a little bit
later on in the class.
But for now, for the start, we'll focus
more on
>> [snorts]
>> deterministic formulation.
Any questions?
Yeah.
>> On the previous slide you talked about
open-loop control,
you mentioned
the
uh
open-loop version
is for a particular state value.
>> Yeah.
>> What exactly does that mean?
And would open or closed-loop have a
similar
relation?
>> I mean, the closed-loop is also a
function of initial state value.
But in addition to that, is also
function of all the future state values.
So basically it's telling you how to
optimally
from all possible state of the worlds.
Keep in mind that the state of the
worlds may not just be modeling where
you are, but also where you are with
respect to everyone
in here
and a control action.
The open loop control
does not take into account what happened
in the future. So once you fixed your
initial condition and you have computed
your control sequence, you're going to
blindly execute on it no matter what
happens.
Does [snorts] it make sense?
Which sounds crazy, but for example
um
if you want to optimize the trajectory
of
a spacecraft that goes to the moon
maybe it's fine actually to consider an
open loop control sequence. In any case
uh
in general you don't really just
optimize an open control control
sequence and then just blindly execute
it. You typically executed it in a
receding horizon manner, meaning that
you will execute the first uh
uh 10%
and then you open your eyes, you see
what happens, and then you recompute a
new open loop control sequence. That's
what will lead us to model predictive
control.
So basically you compute your control
sequence, you close your eye, you move a
little bit you open it, you recompute a
new open control sequence. So you're
doing in a way closed loop control, but
at every point in time you're only
solving open loop control problem, which
is computationally more advantageous.
It's not too difficult, but as I said
there's a bit of nuance there one can
easily get confused. So throughout this
class you'll see a lot of examples, so
by the end of this class uh
will become super obvious. Yeah.
>> What if you have a disturbance
>> Initial conditions are modeled.
We can model it in different ways.
We can model it
indirectly, directly deterministically,
and then directly stochastically. So,
for example, in this formulation here
your
F can also depend on the disturbance WK.
Then we can assume to be generated
randomly
according to some stochastic model
or deterministically, maybe in a game
theoretical setting. So, we assume that
the nature, for whatever reason, is
trying to within some bounds
maximally perturb you. So, this is sort
of a protecting yourself from the worst
case.
Or in general, you can also develop a
control policy
neglecting disturbances explicitly
and just making sure that for example,
you allow enough buffer for your state
trajectory in between state constraints
so that even if there is a little bit of
disturbance, you don't hit anything.
So, there are different ways of modeling
disturbances. But yes, if you want to do
so explicitly
you add a disturbance variable here and
then you have to add a disturbance
model. It could be deterministic, like
worst case, that nature is going to
damage you as much as possible. So, it's
solving the central optimization problem
itself. Or stochastically, it could be
just a random. And we'll see some
variations that are of
throughout the class. So, for example,
we're going to see worst case
disturbances when we talk about
differential games.
And then and then Markov decision
processes. We're going to look at a lot
of
cool problems. Like, have you heard of
the homicidal chauffeur?
Okay, so that's a problem.
I let I let you think about it and then
in a few weeks we'll solve it.
So, you are a car
and you want to get from some initial
condition
to some final condition.
But or actually
you have a pedestrian. You're a
pedestrian.
So, this is you. You want to get from
some initial condition
to some final condition.
But you have a disturbance.
The disturbance is that there is a car.
And the car wants wants to hit you.
So, you might say the situation is
desperate because the car
can go faster than you.
But you're taking this class and you
know how to exploit the dynamics. So,
what's the difference between a car and
a pedestrian?
That a car can go faster than you.
But a pedestrian is omnidirectional. So,
basically you can turn you can turn
uh
uh over yourself, right? So, instead a
car cannot move diagonally. So, at best
you compute this type of trajectories.
So, the problem would be what is the set
of initial conditions
that allow you to get to the final
condition without a car hitting you.
That's one way of solving it. That's one
famous optimal control problem.
There are also some others like the lady
in the lake
where
you are swimming there is a lady that is
trying to swim to the fence but then
there is a monster that is trying to
chase her and there are a lot of things
that we're going to see.
That's a worst case but then there is
also the
We'll see how to solve uh all these
problems.
Great. So,
uh just a few minutes left. So, what
we're going to do in the next
uh
couple of lectures or so
is to take a step back
and recognize that uh
optimal control at the end of the day is
an optimization problem.
Very difficult one because in general we
are solving a either a very high
dimensional problem or even
infinite-dimensional problem, but still
an optimization problem. So, we take a
step back.
We look at the
uh
topic of classical optimization. So,
optimization with uh
uh uh
you know, reasonable number of
variables. We look at what are the main
tools available there
in terms of necessary optimality
conditions, computational methods to
solve an optimum.
And then through that uh throughout the
rest of the class, we'll see how we can
leverage to that intuition to develop
approaches that are tailored to our more
general optimal control problem.
Does it make sense?
Seems a reasonable approach. Let's first
look at the easier problem first, and
then see if there is anything we can use
to solve the problem we care about.
So, what do I mean about uh
a classical optimization problem?
The simplest possible ver- Well, not the
simplest, but one of the simplest
possible version is referred to as
unconstrained nonlinear programming.
You're given a function f.
You're given a vector x that belongs to
Rn. So, this is a vector
of n decision variables, so n numbers
that you get to pick.
I lost the red one. That was the only
one that was working.
Did you steal it? Where is it?
The red one.
So,
x1, x2, dot dot dot xn.
So, this is your vector of decision
variables. You have to assign a number
to each one of these terms, like 0.3
here,
0.6, and up.
And so, you want to find the assignment
to those n decision variables that
minimizes the function f(x).
This is referred to as unconstrained
optimization.
Typically, we assume that F is
continuously differentiable, so we can
take derivatives. And sometimes it is
twice
continuously differentiable.
So, what does it mean for a point to be
an optimum? First of all, we have two
types of optima.
Local minima and global minima.
Local minima means that
a point X star
is a local minimum if when you move
around that point, the function F has a
higher value, larger value.
A point is a global minimum if a point X
star is a global minimum if there is no
other point
or no other assignment for the state
variables that will achieve a lower cost
for F.
More mathematically, we say that a point
is a local a point or a state or
assignment of of variables X star is a
local minimum
if there exists a in neighborhood of X
star
referred defined by
uh the distance between X star, so this
symbol is the same the symbol of a norm,
so the distance.
So, there is a neighborhood around X
star, so all points that uh
are
uh are
displaced by X star no more than
epsilon.
Within that neighborhood,
the cost of the function uh the the
value of the function F is lower than F
of X star.
So, this is X star.
This is for a square norm,
the set of point
whose distance from X star is less than
epsilon.
We are saying that X star is a global is
a local minimum if if I pick any point
from here,
so let's call it this X,
f of X is greater than or equal to f of
X star.
It may be the case that if I pick a
point here,
f of X is less than f of X star. So,
that's why f of X star might just be a
local minimum, but not a global minimum.
If it is a global minimum if no matter
which point I pick
in Rn
or R2 in this case since I'm working on
a plane,
the function f of X is greater than or
equal to f of X star.
So, what we'll see next time is
the notion of a
a necessary optimality conditions. So,
necessary optimality conditions are
conditions that tells you
that tell you if X star is a local
minimum,
then something has to happen.
Then something has to happen. In this
case means that the gradient of f
evaluated at that point should be equal
to zero.
So, why are necessary optimality
conditions useful? Well, for a variety
variety of reasons. One of them being
that they can be used as filters for
candidate for optimality. You just look
at all the points
that satisfy those necessary optimality
conditions.
Hopefully there are not too many. And
then you brute force them. You compute
the value for each one of them. The one
that you choose
lowest value has to be a minimum.
That's one way of of, you know,
looking at the necessary optimality
conditions. So, we derive those. It'll
take us about 15 minutes.
Uh we'll see that actually for this
class of problems the necessary
optimality condition is that the
gradient of f has to be equal to zero.
Later on in the class, we'll see that
this notion of necessary optimality
condition
holds over to the optimal control
problem.
Unfortunately, the condition will be a
bit more complicated, but the notion is
going to be uh the same.
So, we're going to do that, and then
we're going to look at still, uh,
classical optimization,
but where we also account for
constraints. So, we want to
compute a point that is a minimum of F
subject to some function A H be less
than or equal to a number, which bring
us closer to the optimal control
formulation. All right. So, see you on
Wednesday.